if you think and i know it's hard to
compare
players but let's say you at your peak
late 80s 90s and magnus right now if you
played a 12-game match
who do you think would win look again as
i say you know it's the comparison is
is is is flawed because magnus already
learned so much from me and other great
players of the past so uh
and uh if i play today just you know
imagine if you make this
uh mental experiment of taking gary
gaspara from
1990 or 1999 let's say the the time of
uh
league of linares into 2000 2020
it means i have to go through the
opening preparation it will be a
different player so it's still not the
same
you know that's that's why the pure
experiment doesn't work
so um i am you know i could say that
it's what i
you know i i have few events you know
like in 960 game with caruana so
definitely i can tell you that you know
it's if i if i were 20 years younger
i would not make so many blunders
but it's still not the same you know
it's just because the plague magnus is
is really tough because what is
important and that's what's
what i enjoy watching him doing it's the
he he's not he's not standing still
he always tries to improve his chance so
it's it's it's it's very important that
you know
you know while he's so good at the chess
board you know looking for practical
chances
he does a lot of work so it's the it's a
combination of many great players of the
past you know
he's just his car possibility to locate
his pieces in perfect positions
fischer's uh rage at the chess board
and also you know come maybe from myself
from between
you know the the willingness to analyze
these games and just to find improvement
so
it's a it's it's a universal type of
player and
and that's probably explains his his
dominance he's not
he's not fed up with the game even by
winning so many he wants to win more
and that's that's commendable